bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france alors
on le disait 9e journée de mobilisation
qui se prépare un petit peu partout dans
le pays les antilles parce qu'ils ne
faiblissent pas à quoi doit-on
s'attendre
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous en tant
que spécialiste que médecin de celle de
ce mouvement justement contre le passé
ni temps je ne suis pas spécialiste des
antilles pas je suis plutôt spécialiste
du vaccin en tant qu' il s'agit avec ce
très impliqué et tous les jour qui passe
nous montre que cette vaccination est
extrêmement efficace puisque le taux de
contamination est très faible chez les
gens vaccinés puisque le taux
d'hospitalisation est très faible chez
les gens vaccinés et puisque le taux de
décès très faibles se dit jean-max idée
donc la vaccination est très efficace
pour réduire l'impact de l'épidémie ce
notre société et je pense que le pass
and i ter n'est qu'une n'est qu'une la
mise en place de cette vaccination en
préservant des zones sécurisées
notamment les zones de fort impact de
forte contamination que sont les espaces
clos les restaurants les cinémas des
regroupements important les concerts les
stades de foot dans en essayant de
limiter au maximum la diffusion du virus
en ne permettant aux gens vaccinez donc
ils sont moins contaminant qui sont
moins malades de se réunir voilà sept
ans que je ne sais pas je
comprends toujours pas pourquoi on
s'oppose à la vaccination ou pas on voit
même des gens apparemment vaccinés qui
vont manifester je ne comprends pas ceux
ci personnellement dans
l'incompréhension la plus totale
on va bientôt passer à l'automne et la
crainte voilà d'un rebond épidémique est
là est-ce que
voilà cette double vaccination qui
continuent on sait que certaines
personnes aussi vont bientôt peut-être
prendre rendez vous pour une troisième
dose pourra booster un petit peu à
l'immunité contre le virus est ce que
vous craignez justement qu avec ce
mouvement d'anti pas sanitaire qu'on se
retrouve peut-être en plein coeur d'une
nouvelle vague alors on sait on connaît
un peu mieux la fine équipe du virus qui
vient par vagues successives dans la
première qui était très fort quand on a
pas vu venir qu'on a pris 1 figurent la
deuxième la troisième la quatrième qui
est venu plus précocément parce que le
virus avait muté et est devenu beaucoup
plus violent et plus contaminant il y
aura une cinquième wagon tout personne
ne peut dire quand peut-être fin d'année
peut être début d'année prochaine il y
aura une cinquième bague urines 6e
adjointe septième vague sur une victime
vague il le virus procède comme ça plus
il y aura de gens vaccinés plus y aura
de gens immunisés et moi ces vagues
seront importantes et petit petit ce
virus va rentrer dans le lot des virus
respiratoires qui font peu de dégâts et
mais qui sont là de façon constante
peut-être épidémique on ne connaît pas
l'évolution au cours de ce vaccin de
depardon de ce virus savoir si sera
épidémique ou ci sera par par par vagues
mais je crois que on voit l'impact de ce
virus qui devenu très violent très
contagieux très un mutant dangereux on
voit qu'il est agressif pour les jeunes
on voit que cette quatrième vague a fait
finalement beaucoup moins de dégâts que
cantwell estimé et je pense et grâce à
un taux de vaccination important on
n'est pas loin bientôt des 80% des
premières doses donc c'est très
important on voit bien qu'il faut
poursuivre à accélérer ce mouvement de
vaccination pour que la cinquième étape
qui arrivera de toute façon viendra ait
le moins d'impact possible est le moins
de dégâts dans notre société un virus
qui fait aujourd'hui partie de notre vie
finalement
mais qui également à peut-être une
certaine manière discréditer le
gouvernement on sait que on voit ce qui
se passe avec la sphère butin qui est
injuste ça d'être mise en examen
l'ancien ministre de la santé est ce que
voilà il devrait pas y avoir une
communication un petit peu plus clair
peut-être de la part des politiques dans
cette gestion de la crise
alors bon jeu de façon très claire on
n'était pas prêt en janvier février 2000
bâton n'était pas prêt à affronter cette
épidémie on n'était pas prêt le stock de
masques n'était pas là on n'avait pas le
déteste pas de gel hydroalcoolique on
pensait pas qu'ils viendraient parce que
jusqu'au dernier moment je vous rappelle
que tous nous spécialistes pas que les
ministres un des infectiologues des
épines en juillet au le virus est
parfaitement contenu il viendra pas en
france jusque début mars donc en fait on
a été si je laissais 1 on était un
espèce de déni collectif
on pensait que ça ne viendrait pas
est-ce qu'il faut maintenant demander
des comptes à ceux quittant place je ne
sais pas j'ai pas d'avis là dessus si la
juste les faits là sans doute de bonnes
raisons je pense qu'il faut que l'on
apprenne ce tout de nos échecs il faut
qu'on se rappelle toujours que des virus
peut muter peut faire des pandémies des
épidémies et qui fonctionne extrêmement
vigilant qu'au soir sur le qui vive et
qu'on soit prêt et qu'on soit prêt on
n'était pas prêts du tout on n'avait pas
de masque on n'avait rien et donc ça
fait la première vague a fait des dégâts
terribles surtout moi à mulhouse où
l'épidémie a explosé en quelque sorte un
jour on a une ça a été catastrophique il
ne faut pas que ce genre de situation se
reproduise je sais pas si c'est par des
procès que ça va passer mais je pensais
plutôt par une réelle et par une
réflexion collective une prise en compte
de l'ensemble la société de nos
dirigeants qui faut être très méfiant et
il faut être prêt et souhaite équiper
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir réagi
sur notre antenne ce matin
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
généraliste à mulhouse